I think was the jacket yeah I hope so I
think it was the jacket that caused the
win I just want to be louder than the
flowers Hey it's pretty good and Prez
might look right by that right up front
and center yeah let him know you know
where we were already going we're going
no we're done
we weren't it seems so naturalistic no
they thought we were being off the
unaware but we in fact we're going it
started the interview let's go I like
this baby right here yeah she looks
alright they knew they'd be so heavy
they've made it more user friendly it's
a it's a nice bludgeon for any intruders
you can like use it as a weight because
it's like really I think I already have
a my biceps ready got a pretty good
workout oh yeah yeah I'm working out for
that wedding coming up that's true
yeah thanks for reminding me yeah I know
now that you got your award you can yes
I can now we can start doing the real
party exactly how's it feel she's good
it's all feels good I've been you know
it's an amazing moment in my life then I
recognize these things are very fleeting
so you know what can you do it just try
and grab a couple butterflies while
you're in there and you know enjoying
Wally before they fly away I like that
yeah you know I liked her as an actor
and and I've always enjoyed interviewing
but I like you even more that you uh you
thank your mom up there and you said
that she's the reason for everything
good and she's a yeah she's a big
percentage of that I count my many
friends and family and obviously my
beautiful fiance but yeah she probably
gets seniority something before before
the awards I actually texted my dad and
I said just you know don't tell mom but
if things go our way I'm gonna thank mom
I don't want you think I'm not including
you and he said as long like if you if
you honor your mom you honor me so I was
like what it sure made me cry in the car
on the way over here I was a kind an
ugly cry on stage have you talked to
your mom no I'm on my way I can't wait
she here she's around yes she's at one
of the parties we're getting it down so
she you haven't talked to his did you
know I was about to have did you look at
her was she crying I don't know she was
in another room III I had to yield to my
fiance to be with me tonight but she's
with my dad in a room very very nearby
okay what did your fiance say after the
win oh we haven't got to talk either we
just been doing this whole thing do you
imagine somebody like gabab will get
Hera we've got a lot of love you know
will release the hose when I get
one final thing and I gotta let you go
but you said that this doing this was
like being at the the table with all the
cool kids it is it really is I almost
said that up there but I realize it gave
you that to shake it up when I said I I
feel like I've won like a fan contest
you're not getting to hang out with all
these people so yes points in the movie
just all all well you know I'm looking
at you know Brian May of Queen and I'm
looking at Sasha Baron Cohen all these
people that I idolized and it's uh you
know it's an it's an encouraging feeling
and you have their attention and
audience I almost want to apologize to
them
but here we are and you won the award
yes we did at the at the lunch table
yeah at the cool lunch table the cool
table yeah they haven't kicked me out
yet that makes you a cool kid well let's
hope so I think so well thank you I'll
take it I'll take you while I can
[Music]